as you know Donald Trump was arraigned
in New York City and then two nights ago
he went back to Florida he went to
Mar-A-Lago and he gave a speech and most
of the networks were covering it here's
how Rachel Maddow on MSNBC The televised
mental institution known as MSNBC here's
how she chose to cover it
is making remarks tonight from his home
in Florida as far as we can tell and
what we're prepared for here is that
this is basically a campaign speech in
which he is repeating his same lies and
allegations against his perceived
enemies it is just getting started
um so far he's just giving his normal
list of grievances we don't consider
that necessarily newsworthy and there's
a cost to us as a news organization of
knowingly broadcasting untrue things so
our deal with you is that we will
monitor these remarks if he does say
anything newsworthy we will turn them
around and report on that right away but
for now just know that it's happening
and we're not taking it wow Rachel
you're such a journalist you're such a
journalist you won't broadcast untrue
things Hot Diggity Dog where'd we find
this
it means that instead of the vaccine
being able excuse me it means for
instead of the virus being able to hop
from person to person to person to
person spreading and spreading sickening
some of them but not all of them and the
ones that it doesn't stick and don't
know they have it and then they give it
to even more people because they didn't
recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus stops with
every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
okay so everything she said right there
was untrue now you might be going but
Dave she didn't knowingly lie about that
stuff except the problem is she
knowingly swallowed the propaganda that
Pfizer and moderna and the NIH and the
CDC and fauci and everybody else were
putting out there that's not the job of
a journalist that's the job of a public
relations executive and that's what she
acts as while she is on once again the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC Glenn Greenwald who's an actual
journalist an independent journalist who
I actually have some political
disagreements with he watched that clip
of Maddow talking about Trump and he
tweeted this out I thought this was just
perfect he wrote the person talking
about Maddow who won a 30 million dollar
a year Comcast contract by telling
liberals Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation Lab leak was debunked
Trump had secret server with Alpha a
bank Russia put bonus bounties on U.S
soldiers says she's too worried about
the lies to show Trump's speech so you
get it guys you get it
[Music]